this Fox News Alert we have major
breaking news at this hour out of
Afghanistan according to a phone call
just obtained by Reuters from July
President Biden warning the Afghan
president ghani you know the guy that
fled with all that money that the fight
against the Taliban was quote not going
well and that he needed to change the
perception and quote there is a need
whether it's true or not to project a
different picture in other words in July
Biden knew things were going bad going
south the Intel community and we have
been reporting this has been correct
from day one that's why the CIA left six
seven weeks earlier but instead of
stopping the Taliban and stopping a
withdrawal and protecting our interests
Joe Biden was only worried about Optics
projecting a different picture this is a
disgrace because what that means is Joe
Biden knew you that it wasn't working
and was getting dangerous and he didn't
expedite the withdrawal at a point in
time when he could have done it safely
and not leave Americans Behind Enemy
Lines in our Afghan allies to be
murdered and they will be you every
American tonight should be furious to be
blunt we don't have a president in the
white house we don't have a real
commander-in-chief we don't have a
leader instead we have a dishonest
self-involved incoherent mumbling and
bumbling quote commander-in-chief who
firmly believes that he deserves all the
credit for getting the United States out
of Afghanistan none of the blame for the
disaster of how it went down 13 dead
Americans that's our national treasure
and many more seriously wounded and
hundreds of dead Afghans and God only
knows how many Americans are Left Behind
Enemy Lines tonight well basically
hostages of the whims of the terrorist
organization the Taliban to now fend for
themselves now the fact that we don't
know the exact number that alone is
unforgivable this was the worst
self-inflicted foreign policy disaster
in not only modern American history one
of the worst in all of American history
and sadly the only thing I can report
tonight is it is far from over all of
this because of Joe Biden and now we
know he knew all of it was completely
preventable every bit of it he did this
but in a speech today Joe took no
responsibility he offered zero apologies
he patted himself on the back again and
again and again and he took his mission
accomplish in a great Victory lap and he
provided Zero Solutions for now the
scores of our fellow Americans held
hostage abandoned Behind Enemy Taliban
lines
and couldn't this have be done in a more
orderly manner I respectfully disagree
there is not an end to our commitment to
American citizens who are in Afghanistan
who want to leave never in my lifetime
would I ever believe
America would have an Administration
knowingly make a decision to leave
Americans mind it's not completely
unlike the way we do it elsewhere around
the world I mean we have Americans that
get stranded in countries all the time
extraordinary success of this mission
due to the incredible skill bravely and
selfless courage in the United States
military and our diplomats and
intelligence professionals
[Music]
abandoned behind
behind day 17.
every single American this is not
political whether you're Republican
Democrat conservative liberal this
should make every American's blood boil
our fellow Americans now are Behind
Enemy Lines and Hostage to the whims of
the terrorist group the Taliban I guess
after about 10 20 cups of coffee today a
very annoyed looking seemingly wired Joe
Biden screaming into the microphone
lecturing us that the evacuation was a
tremendous success in fact he
congratulated himself and said it could
not have been done in a more orderly way
oh yes it could take a look
I take responsibility for the decision
now some say we should have started mass
evacuation sooner
and couldn't this have be done have been
done in a more orderly manner
I respectfully disagree
respectfully you're dead wrong you could
have done it in April when the Taliban
was on the March May June oh and July
when you knew damn well things were
falling apart wait until later in the
show tonight we will show you exclusive
tape of what's really going on in Joe's
successful Endeavors in Afghanistan if
this was an extraordinary success how
does one Define failure Joe Biden
obviously lying Afghans falling from
American airplanes and airports
surrounded by terrorists Americans and
our partners held Behind Enemy Lines
unable to get through rescued missions
conducted by private For Hire security
groups and retired military personnel
that just cared enough to go get their
fellow Americans and Afghan allies
because Biden wasn't sending any help
even the Dutch and the Brits and the
French were sending in Troopers Behind
Enemy Lines to save their people 83
billion dollars According to some
estimates the sophisticated U.S Weaponry
now in the hands of an evil terrorist
organization all courtesy of Joe Biden
because he didn't prepare but he knew
now we know he knew a massive terror
attack killing 13 American Service men
and women more than 160 innocent
civilians Pegram Air Force Base has now
gone our U.S embassy is gone we have no
diplomatic presence on the ground we
have no military presence on the ground
our Intel sources are being hunted down
and they will be killed one by one
they're even we even left behind not
only computer data identifying every
Afghan Ally in the last 20 years but
they've got we left the biometric
scanners yeah they have those too look
into this right now oh you help the
Americans you're dead and now hundreds
maybe more than a thousand American
citizens are trapped Behind Enemy Lines
that's right stuck at the whims of the
Taliban that now hold their fate in
their hands no way out their fate now
rests with the Good Will and mercy of
several terrorist organizations
including the Taliban including Isis K
including Al Qaeda who are now all
emboldened you know Joe Biden said oh we
have all the leverage you don't have any
leverage our own Jennifer Griffin
reporting rightly so that multiple
American babies whose parents are green
card holders unable to get past the
Taliban to get to the airport they're
trapped Behind Enemy Lines CNN's
Clarissa Ward I think did a phenomenal
job talked about a family from Texas all
with U.S passports who were also unable
to escape a three-year-old American Boy
from Sacramento California couldn't also
get out also trapped tonight and last
night an interview with a with an
American woman named Sarah who is all so
desperate to get out herself you know
what you don't think this could have
gone any better Joe you don't think that
doing this in May June July we show you
the map every night we give you the
dates and the time and and the quick
geographical possession of the Taliban
you knew they were on the March now the
Intel Community is releasing information
because they're not going to take blame
for your mistake do you really think
anyone's going to buy your lies from
today do you think we're that dumb are
you that dumb this evacuation could not
have been any worse and it's going to
get worse but get this according to Joe
we're all just overreacting Americans
Behind Enemy Lines we left them behind
something I never thought I'd see in my
lifetime and I'm overreacting
I don't think so take a look
we believe that about 100 to 200
Americans remain in Afghanistan
with some intention to leave
most of those who remain are dual
citizens
long-time residents who had earlier
decided to stay because of their family
roots in Afghanistan
the bottom line
90 percent of Americans in Afghanistan
who wanted to leave were able to leave
he bragged we got 5 500 Americans out
but what was it less than two weeks ago
he said oh I think there's 10 or 15 000
Americans we are the United States of
America the most powerful country with
the best military on the face of this
Earth we don't leave our fellow
Americans behind not one not two not ten
percent how would you like it if ten
percent of your family was trapped in
Afghanistan right now Joe how would that
sit with you and don't forget thousands
of our Afghan partners are also trapped
Behind Enemy Lines they are being hunted
down as we speak by the Taliban and they
will all be executed and according to
the Wall Street Journal an interpreter
that actually rescued Joe Biden and
several other Senators 13 years ago
during a horrible snowstorm in
Afghanistan when their helicopter had to
be landed he's now hiding marked for
dead he had begged Joe to get him out
Joe didn't care in fact he refused to
take any responsibility at all according
to Joe the buck does not stop with him
in spite of his words that he read off a
teleprompter that somebody else clearly
wrote and gave him 15 cups of coffee so
he could actually stay awake for more
than 10 minutes he blamed the Afghan
Army the Afghan government the Americans
trapped Behind Enemy Lines his own
advisors and then when all else fails
let's just blame Donald Trump for
everything take a look
in April I made a decision to end this
war
when the Afghan Security Forces after
two decades of fighting for their
country and losing thousands of Their
Own
did not hold on as long as anyone
expected the people of Afghanistan
watched their own government collapse
and the president flee amid the
corruption of malfeasance since March
we reached out 19 times to Americans in
Afghanistan
with multiple warnings
and offers to help them leave
Afghanistan all the way back as far as
March my predecessor the former
president
sign an agreement with the Taliban to
remove U.S troops by May the 1st just
months after I was inaugurated the
decision to end the military lift
operations at Kabul Airport was based on
the unanimous recommendation
of my civilian and Military advisors
stop blaming Trump and if you want the
truth we'll give you the truth about the
Trump deal here are the facts it was a
conditional agreement for they have a
negotiated a thing Donald Trump warned
the Taliban if they didn't follow every
dotted I cross T every comma every
period they would be obliterated if they
broke the rules they'd be obliterated
just like baghdadi and Associates just
like the al-Qaeda leader that Donald
Trump took out in Yemen just like the
Iranian terrorists solimani if they
marched on Kabul while Americans were
still all over the country they knew
they would be obliterated just like he
did to the caliphate the Taliban knew
this and for 18 months that's right over
a year when Donald Trump is last year in
office not a single solitary American
was killed inside of Afghanistan so make
no mistake and watch that timeline we
could have gotten out in April May June
July and we didn't do it and he now we
know he knew now we know he wanted to
create a false facade under no
circumstances would Donald Trump have
abandoned Bagram Air Force Base while
any American citizen was still inside
the country as a matter of fact his plan
was to keep it in perpetuity we built it
we owned it that was what he said to me
only an idiot would have abandoned that
air base and now Americans are Partners
it are Afghan allies they're all trapped
they're all hostages they're all caught
Behind Enemy Lines Al Qaeda and Isis are
on the rise and the Taliban that Terror
organization that participated and was a
safe haven in the lead up to the 9 11
attacks has full control of that country
and a massive new stockpile of brand new
the latest greatest Weaponry that Joe
Biden gave them Joe keeps talking about
well we have leverage an international
pressure we don't have any leverage Joe
none our Embassy is gone our soldiers
are gone and they have Americans Behind
Enemy Lines they would be called
hostages Joe and pretending that the
Taliban care about their standing in the
world well you're just full of Adam's
Schiff they're terrorist Joe they let
other terrorists from Isis and Al Qaeda
out of prison Joe they don't give an
atom shift what you and 100 other
countries think they're going door to
door as we speak they're executing
political enemies Afghan Army personnel
and pilots and musicians and Comedians
and make no mistake anyone with American
ties inside of Afghanistan will be a
target for murder so you want to know
the grand master plan to rescue
Americans now Behind Enemy Lines Biden
is going to use your tax dollars we have
economic Leverage
where I grew up in New York we kind of
call that Ransom take a look
you say we're going to work with the
Taliban does that include the prospect
of giving them Aid
well first of all we do believe that
there is an important dimension of
humanitarian assistance that should go
directly to the people of Afghanistan
when it comes to our Economic and
Development assistance relationship with
the Taliban that will be about the
taliban's actions it will be about
whether they follow through on their
commitments
oh acquitted a pro and a quote with Joe
oh that's familiar try that Joe it's
illegal you should be impeached frankly
you're unfit to serve as it is
apparently bribery doesn't work those
who want to get out will be trapped
forever now some will be tortured and
killed the world will see it I hope to
God I'm wrong I don't think I am others
will live under the constant fear of the
taliban's reign of terror left behind by
a President Who once vowed to protect
all Americans and leave no one behind
for any reason take a look
if there's American citizens left we're
going to stay low get them all out this
town this state
takes care
nobody be
giving everyone a fair shot leaving
nobody behind
that we do take care of our own
that we leave nobody behind they help
everyone in need look out for one
another Leave Nobody behind but we will
leave no one behind
it's what America is all about
it's about pulling together leaving
nobody behind
giving hate no Safe Harbor
social fabric
that holds the society together honesty
decency hope
leaving nobody behind
lie after lie after lie meaningless
words from a spineless you know career
politician who only cares about himself
if he even knows what day of the week it
is doesn't seem to care Americans are
trapped Behind Enemy Lines and the worst
part of this is it was all preventable
doesn't care that our Afghan Partners
have been abandoned and they'll likely
be murdered doesn't seem to care that 13
American Heroes died because of his
disastrous withdrawal over the weekend
after Joe checked his watch repeatedly
during the dignified transfer a relative
of one of our fallen soldiers reportedly
yelled across the tarmac at Joe I hope
you burn in hell her feelings her anger
her grief you want to know why because
it didn't need to happen and she said
Joe has blood on his hands and now more
Americans uh than that now see he
abandoned our fellow Americans in
Afghanistan what are they going to do
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else